Movie bloopers are a lot of fun, plain and
simple.
Film fans love to watch actors flub.
And considering the way they make themselves
and their co-stars laugh when it happens,
actors clearly love bloopers too.
Filmmakers, on the other hand, may not love
them quite as much.
Every time an actor makes a mistake, it delays
the shoot just a little, and time is money.
And every so often, they're forced to deal
with a truly world-class mess-up — a mistake
that costs the production big money due to
property damage and personal injury.
Seven
Brad Pitt suffered a nasty injury on the set
of Seven.
During one scene that called for him to chase
his suspect in the rain, he slipped and smashed
his hand into a windshield, severing a tendon.
Director David Fincher mentions on the film's
DVD commentary that Pitt showed him his wound,
which was so severe he could see the white
of the bone.
Making the best of a bad situation, Fincher
managed to incorporate Pitt's injury into
the story of Seven by having the script rewritten
to have Pitt's character suffer an injury
in the line of duty.
It added time and expense to the production
schedule.
But it was probably a lot cheaper to explain
why one of the film's main characters was
suddenly wearing a cast than simply delaying
shooting long enough for Pitt to recover.
Still, it didn't solve the problem completely:
like most movies, Seven was shot out of sequence,
so any earlier scene filmed after Pitt's injury
required the actor to hold his bad hand in
his pocket or behind his back.
Skyfall
According to writer and filmmaker Charlie
Lyne, the 2012 James Bond adventure Skyfall
had to deal with some unplanned expenses because
star Daniel Craig wore a pair of leather gloves
at the wrong moment.
As Lyne told the story via Twitter, which
he heard from someone who worked on the film,
Craig asked director Sam Mendes if he could
wear a pair of leather gloves in a particular
scene.
Mendes agreed, and the cast and crew got down
to work filming a sequence in which a bad
guy gets Bond's gun away from him, only to
find he can't fire it because it has a fingerprint
scanner — it will only work for Bond.
"There's a microdermal sensor in the grip.
It's been coded to your palmprint so only
you can fire it."
Months later in the editing bay, a production
assistant noticed a problem:
"Then how is Bond ever going to fire it wearing
gloves?
And so silence falls across the room."
After considering the costs of reshooting
the scene, the filmmakers decided it would
be cheaper — although still quite expensive
— to digitally remove the gloves from Craig's
hands for the entire sequence.
"If you watch the scene now, honest to god,
you can see that Bond has these ridiculously
pudgy hands.
He has these, like, Mr. Blobby hands.
Because in every single frame, he's wearing
these thick leather gloves that have been
painted over with Craig-toned hands.
The Hateful Eight
To play the crafty outlaw Daisy Domergue in
Quentin Tarantino's The Hateful Eight, Jennifer
Jason Leigh had to learn how to play the guitar.
The lucky actress got to learn on the same
one she'd strum in the film: a vintage Martin
guitar dating to the 19th century, loaned
to the movie by the Martin Guitar Museum.
Leigh's big guitar-playing moment on screen
was all planned out: while she was playing,
co-star Kurt Russell was supposed to grab
it.
The scene would cut and the Martin would be
traded out for a cheaper prop guitar, which
Russell would smash when the cameras started
to roll again.
But that isn't what happened — instead,
Russell grabbed the real Martin from Leigh
and smashed it.
"Gimme that guitar."
"Music time's over!"
Leigh later told Billboard, "Kurt felt terrible;
he had no idea."
Justice League
Sometimes it's not the actor who goofs up,
it's the studio responsible for the movie
— and then they have to fork out the cash
to make things right.
Warner Bros. had to reassemble the cast of
Justice League in the summer of 2017 for some
crucial reshoots.
Henry Cavill, who plays Superman, was among
those summoned, but there was a problem: He'd
grown a mustache for his next role, in the
sixth Mission: Impossible movie, and was contractually
obliged to keep it until M:I 6 was finished
filming.
The facial hair scheduling snafu left Justice
League's visual effects technicians with the
job of digitally removing Superman's mustache.
Effects expert Dave Fleet told Business Insider
it could cost millions: "We would need to
build a 3D model of the face and then shade
the surface of the skin to look realistic.
We would then need to track the 3D model to
the movement of his head and potentially re-animate
his mouth."
"That mustache has got to go!
It makes you look like a total geek…
It makes you look like a total geek…"
The Avengers
Marvel's superhero team isn't the only Avengers
in pop culture.
There's also The Avengers, a 1960s British
spy TV series.
The 1998 film adaptation starring Ralph Fiennesand
Uma Thurman was a critical and commercial
bomb, but the movie made headlines for another
type of detonation.
While the crew filmed an explosion for the
movie, a few rogue sparks drifted away and
hit the roof of the studio, starting a fire
that was definitely not part of the plan.
A set worth a reported $1.6 million was destroyed,
along with the hopes of any sequel.
"Never trust the weather, Sir August."
"Rain or shine, all is mine!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!